le coût de la vie qui ne cesse
d'augmenter des actions insuffisantes
pour lutter contre la crise climatique
c'est l'argumentaire de ces milliers de
manifestants qui arpentent les rues de
Paris la majorité des gens aujourd'hui
sont
réduits à 1500 euros et vont payer 500
euros d'essence est-ce que le but d'un
travail c'est pas de gagner de l'argent
c'est pas de s'enrichir en ton choix peu
pour faire profiter nos enfants de
peut-être d'activités il y a pas non
plus de choses qui sont faites pour le
climat pour notre avenir et donc nous on
se demande dans cette société là quelle
est notre place au milieu des drapeaux
toute la gauche est représentée a
commencé par l'ex-candidat à la
présidentielle Jean-Luc Mélenchon
initiateur de ce rendez-vous il est
accompagné de la prix Nobel de
littérature Annie Ernaux les
manifestants réclament entre autres du
gouvernement Macron des gels de prix les
augmentations de salaires au-delà de
l'inflation et des investissements à
hauteur de centaines de milliards
d'euros dans la transition écologique
[Musique]
cette marche survient en pleine grève
dans les raffineries de Total qui
entraînent des pénuries de carburant et
à l'approche d'une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation initiée par la
Confédération générale du travail prévue
mardi au début il nous traitent
d'ailleurs que le mouvement de grève ne
se propage à d'autres secteurs de
l'économie aussi les centrales
nucléaires dont on commence à parler
mais aussi le ferroviaire et là à partir
du moment où on parle de grève à la SNCF
qui est la compagnie nationale à la RATP
c'est à dire les les transports
parisiens là on se dit que ça risque de
faire mal d'autant que un des syndicats
qui appellent à cette journée d'action
parlent de grève peut-être reconductible
dans les dans les transports
de travail chez Total paralyse le pays
depuis près de trois semaines ici Daniel
Kadjo Radio-Canada Montréal